one of the many things I firmly firmly
firmly believe in that anybody who
learns the skillsets of a millionaire
can become a millionaire when I say
anybody I literally mean generally
anybody - any health disabilities things
like that you see I'm wearing this shirt
here that says enjoy capitalism because
capitalism may not be a 100 percent
perfect system I've lived in a
socialistic environment lived not
vacation live and I've lived in a
dictatorship environment I've lived with
a family members who were half my family
were all communist and an imperialist I
believe in capitalism and many of my
followers ship who followed these the
content on value tainment from all
around the world 220 countries that
follow this content you will know I will
constantly encourage people to study
this system this model because it works
effectively now some people don't like
that but it's what I believe in firmly
and in you know when people say well you
don't understand I didn't come from a
rich family at income I didn't come from
a rich family my dad worked at a 99-cent
store for 15 years my parents got a
divorce my mother had to go back to Iran
because she ran out of money I'm a
welfare child I joined the army I had a
1.8 GPM the last person in our high
school you asked any one of my high
school buddies will tell you I'm the
last person anybody would have ever
expected to become successful but
because III one event father having a
heart attack on in the hospital seen him
lose 40 pounds one event made me
completely change this guy and not not
temporary change a lot of people change
temporarily I'm going to get into my
message here I'm talking permanent
change I know a lot of people that will
work hard for 90 days and then they go
back to the bad habits they'll exercise
for 90 days then they go back to the bad
habits don't keep a good time for 90
days I will go back to the bad habits
they'll read books for 90 days then I'm
talking permanent permanent obsession
change that is going to last with you
for 10 20 30 40 50 years that's what
it's going to take to be able to make
the kind of money that millionaires make
the money is out there the money
circulates it doesn't stay in a place
this money that I have right now my
pocket I want you to think about this
here this this $200 here
guess what ask the question how many
people you think this is touched
how many people has this touched how
many people it touches thousands and
thousands of hands have touched this and
it's with me now I can choose to do
whatever I can do with this $200 but
it's going to keep circulating and
eventually hands end up getting the most
those who learn the skill sets of
attracting this and retaining it and
growing it that's what I want to talk
about here with you today I did a video
a few months back it was titled how to
really become a millionaire entrepreneur
put it up it became the number one video
on entrepreneurs YouTube channel and
then for us it's done very very well
let's matter if I put a link on here on
the bottom it's called how to really
become a millionaire let's put the
images all so people can see what it
looks like today I want to talk about
the 11 skill sets that millionaires
master ok and I'm going to get very
detailed about this on these areas for
them to master and then you got to make
a choice yourself that whether you want
to kind of pass up on this and just kind
of show great video path phenomenal
video men as usual great content to me
what I love the most is the type of
messages I love the most is when a guy
sends me a message and says I started
watching your videos about a year ago
and I followed all the content that
you've I've never missed a single lady i
watch every one of your videos a year
ago I made $7,000 this last month I made
ninety three thousand dollars in a month
I like that I like it when somebody
tells me our company grossed three
million dollars last year this year on
track to grossing thirteen million
dollars those are the messages I like
you because they're implementing and
growing so you will get the content it's
on you to implement it so let's go
through number one and by the way I'm
assuming you automatically have to have
work ethic I'm not even going to put
work ethic as a point because it's not a
skill set it's a mentality but if you
don't work none of these things are
going to affect you in any possible way
maybe a little bit but not dramatically
let's let me get right into a number one
skill set that generally millionaires
master is persuasion and let me explain
to what I mean by persuasion what I mean
you know they master persuasion to me is
on many different fronts one they have
to persuade their family that I'm going
to go become an entrepreneur please
support me they have to persuade their
wife if they're married their husband if
they're married they have to persuade
their kids
parents peers they have to persuade
investors they have to persuade an
employee to want to come work with them
when they're small to have to persuade a
group of salespeople to want to come and
sell their product they have to persuade
people on why their product is a special
product they have to persuade why their
industry is a special industry on what
type of an impact that's made in your
life you got to learn how to persuade
people you gotta learn how to persuade
when they're selling the customer when
your product may not yet be at the level
you want it to be you need to learn how
to persuade investors on why they oughta
invest into your company you need to
persuade executives and talent who are
with established companies why ought to
why should they consider even working
with something like you working with an
entrepreneur like you who is maybe not
established yet maybe you're not there
yet you know you've got to learn how to
persuade your competitors persuade your
partners persuade your vendors persuade
your carrier's persuade there's a lot of
persuasion that you got to do by the way
you also you got to learn to persuade
yourself as well you got to psych
yourself out to get into the mode of
wanting to get to work on a daily basis
especially those days that you know it's
not an exciting that you got to persuade
yourself persuasion is one of their
skill sets you got to persuade when you
learn how to negotiate negotiation is a
form of persuasion learning how to sell
if you don't know how to sell kiss
entrepreneurship goodbye because selling
is a form of persuasion negotiation is a
form of persuasion speaking from stage
is a form of persuasion not everybody
speaks the same style but you know
everything there is persuasion number
one skills that I put up there is
persuasion number two number two let me
tell you one thing that you know most
millionaires master is reading people
reading people and I'll and I'll tell
you what I mean by reading people okay
the reason why reading people
millionaires end up generally becoming
good at reading people is because
they've been ripped off backstab the lie
- cheated so many times that there are a
lot of signals that they see a trend
that saying this person's like that
reminds me of this person you gotta
learn how to read people gotta learn how
to read a customer you gotta learn how
to read an employee you got to learn how
to read someone who is absolutely full
of it sometimes I get surprised how some
people who are pretty successful
making 100 200 300 thousand dollars a
year how easily they fall for the trap
of somebody who's full of it like how do
you not read that sometimes right you
gotta learn how to read it and in a
certain level of paranoia when you're
reading people and then also when I'm
saying reading people it's not just on a
negative side reading people on someone
that's truly you did something wrong and
you need to go out there and do
something about it you need to read
people that need you to make a right
effort to take care of them you don't
make the right effort to you know treat
them in a way that they need to be
treated that's also reading people
another one is when I say reading people
is being able to think what a customer
is going to need now where the
customer's going to need a year from
that three years from now five years
from now and reading them being able to
read a person that starts with your
company at an early stage and what were
they thinking about when they were at
your level at a new level you're not
speaking to them from your level
millionaires they got to learn how to
read somebody at that level and give
them the belief that they need at that
level versus somebody that's been around
a little longer that needs to kind of
man up or woman up or mature as an
entrepreneur and they're not they're
just treating this as a lollygagging
with the industry that's a complete
different conversation with that person
say grow up already you've been in this
thing for five 10 15 years what's next
you're going to be like this your entire
life so reading to know when where who
what when they eventually become very
good at reading people number three this
one's going to sound strange to a lot of
people I first say but it'll make sense
to hear in a minute it's called sharing
the wealth
hang tight this is not a hokey corny
type of thing I'll explain to what I
mean by sharing the wealth the people
that I've met who have created lots of
wealth I live in a nice community and
you know I go to the guy across the
street he's a guy who was part of a
technology software company he was one
of the many guys that became very
wealthy when this company was bought out
I go to the guy on the other side lives
in a six and a half million dollar house
they built you know 5 10 15 20 different
dealerships berkshire hathaway came and
bottom they weren't the biggest
dealership here in town in dallas in
texas they bottom out he was one of the
many people who all experienced a lot of
wealth and
lots of money I go and sit down with
people who were part of startups and
hears stories of so many people you look
at Microsoft on why they kept growing
Apple when it kept growing when when
Steve Jobs died most people don't know
this he only owned 0.6% of Apple stock
think about it the CEO the founder only
ended up owning point six percent of
stock now some people said was because
he left he went to next and he saw nada
okay I get it
still 0.6% Microsoft Bill Gates so many
people became wealthy with Microsoft so
many people became wealthy with Amazon
so many people become well anything
that's ever at the highest scale wealth
has to be created by multiple multiple
people the Clippers organization is
owned by former employee of Microsoft
the Seattle is at Seattle Seahawks and a
you know Paul Allen Trailblazers it's
owned by pockets of former Microsoft so
when you go and study this you will
notice that a lot of people who create
their wealth do with that way I remember
one time I had a gentleman I was working
with and he was a he was Jewish and he
would always tell me things about why
the Jewish community has money and makes
money and so say you know in a very very
vocal guy big personality always had
money always made money and everybody
that touched him also made money with
him I said so you know what is it he
says let me tell you the key to success
to the Jewish community business people
I said what is it he said when we make
money a lot of people make money he says
you know what happens when you make
money a lot of people make money and so
what's that everybody constantly wants
to go in business with you because why
every time they go in business with you
who makes money a lot of people make
money so you keep getting people that
keep coming and doing business with you
now some of you may say that's not try
know this guy that he made his money and
it was all him and all this fine he's
probably not going to get a lot of
people are gonna want to follow him and
do business with him from the past
if you generally see that nobody from
the past is consistently doing business
with a person it's either that person
shows it's the other people said when he
makes money only he makes money nobody
else makes money you gotta learn how to
share the wealth where you continuously
have deals for the rest of your life
number four
leverage
very critical leverage millionaires
master leverage they are master at
understanding leverage and I think one
of the reasons why they understand
leverages the sooner you learn that in
order to do anything big you need a team
is a sooner you'll start scaling at a
very fast pace you know especially a lot
of the driven self-motivated guys that
had high GPAs or did very good in school
and they have good grades and they were
always good at doing the homework right
and nobody does it better than me I'm
I'm perfectionist they typically have
the hardest time they typically have the
hardest time the guys that didn't have
the best grades and they were kind of
played a little bit of sports they
generally don't have a hard time with
this you know why because they've always
needed help so it's kind of manly now I
need help I still need help but the ones
that typically have independent league
we're very good in homework they have a
hard time knowing that they need help
leverage is a very very big deal so you
got to learn how to delegate
what are you delegate will you not
delegate how do you manage and study a
certain thing that you're delegating to
somebody to see if they can fully come
through with it crowd sourcing at one of
my favorite questions to ask our staff
are it doesn't matter who it is I love
to ask what do you think what do you
think about this what do you thing about
this idea what do you think about that
what do you think about this what are
your thoughts and I like to ask every
different type of personality somebody
who is very skeptical but very technical
and smart somebody who is action excited
to me what gets you excited about that
somebody who's normally in the middle
and you don't get a lot of reaction I
want to see all because I want to know
what they think about it that's part of
leverage so leverage is you know team
recruiting sales software technology
social media everything marketing
branding collaborating everything is
leverage how can i leverage to make this
thing go faster leverage number five
number five this is a skill set they
master let me tell you recruiting
recruiting recruiting recruiting let me
explain you recruit a media platform to
want to build you up you recruit talent
you recruit executives you recruit the
best salespeople you recruit people who
our friends that want to go into
business with you recruits solid high
identity associations you recruit good
friends you recruit you know other
people who are extremely successful that
also want to associate with you you
recruit that that's not to sell them
anything that's to sit down and talk and
you're learning from one another you
recruit a board you recruit an advisory
board you recruit the best mentors
millionaires are great at recruiting the
best mentors partners investors they're
incredible at networking they're
incredible at connecting they're
incredible i doing any of those things
because recruiting to them they know I
am one executive away from scaling my
business and you double my revenues and
one salesperson away or one sales leader
away from incredibly growing my sales
volume of sales by fifty one hundred two
hundred three hundred percent if I get
one strong sales leader if I get one
leader that comes in and does they know
that so everything to them is about
recruiting point number six this one's
also strange but I'll tell you energy
management energy management what is
energy management
I still don't drink coffee I just got
off the phone with a major player at the
AIG who sent me a very very nice gift
mark thank you for sending that nice
gift that you send out but we were
talking about energy and it says you got
a newborn are you getting any sleep I
said yeah I'm trying to get some
sleeping and we're getting it waking up
every two hours with the baby and says
are you still not drinking coffee I said
I'm still not drinking coffee so do you
do Red Bull do you do this how don't do
any of that stuff I personally don't do
any of that stuff but I have to figure
out a way on how to manage my energy
because my energy without it I can't do
anything and anybody who becomes a
millionaire those who don't
they generally quit at some point they
quit out $100,000 income they could add
150 200 300 400 sat some point okay some
people go to the very end and then they
quit when they die but a lot of people
quit after 234 years of going all-in
most people don't go for a long time
keep that part of mine so energy
management is what can I do for you for
me to increase my energy so generally I
get tired after working 8 hours I don't
want to get tired after 8 hours what can
I do maybe I'm gonna
ten hours maybe I want to go 12 hours so
I like to stand up and work because this
won't stand my body is standing up so
every time I'm doing this my body is
moving and when I sit now I may take a
break and I sit my energy goes lower
then boom I stand up again my body's
moving things are happening so figuring
out ways to managing your energy to know
how long you can go figuring out how you
can go on little to no sleep I know that
sounds strange to some people how do you
do that your fitness routine your diet
all of that is part of energy management
number seven anybody who's been
following my content for a while you
know I made a video that was called the
most important thing to teach my year
children right and it's called what how
to process issues millionaires learn how
to process issues they learn how to
problem-solve they learn how to sit
there and say if we need this we need to
do this this this this they know how to
think about a prominent come out with a
one two three step to doing something we
need to figure this part out let's call
that person they call this person call
this person email that guy call this guy
let me call this person and say okay we
got it here's what we need to do that
person's willing to do this that person
is not interested but we need to call
them back in the next six months but all
this stuff that goes but it's purely on
learning how to process issues and a
part of learning how to process issues I
put this point it was going to be
separate but I added in this is within
processing issues where everybody is
always bringing them ideas we should do
this we should buy this we should do
that we should do that they also become
very good at saying no to 90% of things
keep that part amount they say no to 90%
of things because they're trying to
identify which areas worth them putting
their time into and not their time into
which areas worth them putting their
resources into and not putting their
resources into which is part of
processing issues number eight number
eight is time management they learn time
management and generally you learn time
management because a lot of times a
rookie entrepreneur may not even make it
because they're spending way too much
time on Facebook newsfeed they're
spending way too much time on a game or
they're spending way too much time on
snapchat fall on everybody else they're
spending way too much time on Instagram
or all that other stuff and they're not
putting a lot of time into selling sell
in front and front end prospect and
prospect in creating creating networking
networking relationship relationship
they're not
they're not in the hunt right so you
don't make it you go straight to the
cemetery of entrepreneurs who are
millions and billions of people buried
there who didn't make it they tried and
they didn't make you their time
management is when you learn how to make
a one and a half hour appointment become
an hour and still effective how you
learn a 30 minute phone call to become
10 minutes how you learn to leave a
message that's an effective message yet
it's not a 6 minute message or formatted
message they learn how to say a message
in a bit of a faster way they know what
area they don't need to put time on and
say this is relationship I'm not putting
a deadline on this because this is
relation because sometimes you can also
be the complete opposite without care
I've got to go and then Dada
the other person is offended by because
they're also busy and you're busy it's
kind of like listen I'm as busy as you
are so don't give me this I'm busy type
of thing everybody's busy at this point
so sometimes people that play that card
when they're not it kind of rubs people
the wrong way who have already they're
already in the hunt at a high different
levels of time management they
understand it but they become very good
on the time management side work hours
week all in you know it's strange how
they still find ways to save their
sanity because you have to stay sane to
go long-term you don't hear a lot of the
people that make it to the highest of
highest of levels taking way too many
vacations you generally don't hear that
but they'll do a schedule of Saturday
boom go Sunday and a Monday they come
back to refuel use your here time on
Sunday being at a spa or hotel all day
and laying out and to relax and you'll
see them doing those sorts of things for
them to reenergize a lot of rookie
entrepreneurs I get two hundred two
hundred three hundred four hundred
thousand all your income vacation
vacation vacation making sure make and
their one or how come they don't
absolutely explode on scale because
they're more concerned about vacation
rather than doing the work so that is a
part of the millionaires mindset as well
nine how to manage money they they have
to you have to learn how to manage money
because everything to you is risk
everything to you is you have these type
of resources and is depleting what can
you do to make the number keep coming up
so the income is increasing your your
savings that you have all in place
accounting
I mean go buying something you can't
afford or can't afford I remember when
we first started a company a PHP agency
I told my wife I said for five years I'm
not buying a house and she said babe we
can afford to buy a house I said I'm
telling you I'm not buying the house for
five years babe it's only $300,000 down
payment maybe I'm not buying a house for
five years and I made it very clear so
she knew I don't even want to talk about
buying a house because everything that
came in is gone back into the business
everything we rented for the first five
years of me being and we had we could
afford to buy a house but we rent it we
rented we rented we rent it and then we
bought a house then it's a different
story um why because I could do a lot
more with that $300,000 in the company
then I could with $300,000 down payment
on the house or $600,000 down payment on
house why would I want to do that I
don't want to do that I want to stretch
the money and make that six hundred
thousand six million dollars why would I
want to tie that money up to something
automatically right now I don't need to
be doing that so risking it saving to be
able to risk more one of the things
about Apple that they're known for is
they're very much about cash and the
reason why they're always been known as
stingy or all this criticism that people
gave to Apple they have cash to make
decisions Google has cash to make
decisions how much companies have cash
to make decisions and when you have cash
when you want to buy something party you
can do that so cash is a very very big
part of a manager money as well so
number nine is how to manage money
number ten is how to be aggressively
patient this is kind of strange because
how do you become aggressively patient
one you are so aggressive and assertive
on your part on what you can do to grow
but psychologically your patient to know
everything's going to work out because
listen I'm telling you the reason why I
believe anybody and everybody could
become a millionaire anybody and
everybody could become a millionaire
because there's a formula to it and some
of the people that hate it when I say
that is because they tried and they quit
too early or they don't want to work
that hard so it upsets them because they
would rather have an escape to say it's
not true you have to be smart you have
to be from a wealthy family I'm not
smart I'm not from a wealthy family I
learn I read 11 12
books because I was just feeding my mind
constantly so it's not nice I don't come
from a wealthy or very intelligent
intellectual type I come from a simple
hard-working families what I come from
so but you're gonna have to learn a part
that it's just working working working
working working working patient patient
patient I know it's coming I know it's
coming I know it's coming I know it's
coming I know it's coming working
working working working working and the
reason why patients would come say
whatever product you sell so let's just
say it's real estate if I know every
week I plant 100 new seeds whether it's
for a loan officer that I can build a
relationship for him to use me as a
realtor whether it's to hard core
accountants that are working in a market
that I want him to refer me as a realtor
to their client whether it's a community
of everybody that buys and sells homes
every week I add hundred people to my
scene I'm planting 100 seeds 2 weeks
that means I've how many how many seats
200 seats 3 300 seats 400 500 600 700
800 9 I know something's about to happen
I know I'm about to get a call and say
hey Patrick this is John giving you
called you and I met about three months
ago and you were realtor we got your car
look we're thinking about selling our
house and we'd like to get together with
you we really like your approach are you
available for us to get together later
on today
sure excellent because I'm doing this
I'm guaranteed to get this I know for a
fact this is going to happen most people
the reason why they don't get this
they're like there's these three guys if
they buy the house from me I'm going to
be a millionaire there's just two people
if they do business with me they're just
waiting on those two three peoples not
going to work seed seed seed seed seed
seed seed bomb patient comment it comes
then all of a sudden when this thing
when the floodgates open let me tell you
better get the band to be ready when the
floodgates opens then it's just like
then you're saying I can't meet today
but here's what I could do I can send
one of my associates to meet with you
and you can come to my office tomorrow
now you're not going now that people
come in to you because demands high on
you everybody wants to work with you
have credibility that's what I mean by
aggressively patient and the last one
I'll make you to you last one I'll make
to you here is this those
skill sets that these millionaires
master one of the skill sets that they
master is a learning this kind of
straight view master learning yes
they're constantly focused on improving
they're constantly focused on
improvement how can I become better in
this how can I become better than that
how can I become better in this how can
I make the company matter how can I make
the customer service better how can I
make the product better how can I make
my communication skill level better how
can I make my this level how can I make
everything is about improving everything
today how can we beat our prior best
what's the most we ever did in here 68
let's do 72 this month what's the most
we ever done over here we have 102 let's
try to break that number what it was the
most you ever done it was the most cause
you made intimate what's the most
appointment you ran in a week what's it
everything is let's beat that let's beat
that let's beat that let's beat that
let's beat that because it's always
constantly about improvement then all of
a sudden every department is getting
better and improving every department is
getting better and improvement so
they're learning they're all about self
education they have a big dinners
mindset let me explain sometimes when
you see people that are made money and
they're extremely cocky they no longer
have the beginner's mindset they've
already surpassed what they thought
they're going to make money wise so
beginner's mindset is somebody that's so
curious how do I do this how do I get
this better what do I do about this how
do I do that
how do I get this thing what do I do
that what everything is about learning
learning learning learning learning
that's all they're do they want to learn
Lorne Lorne is what they're doing right
so everything is about consummating
their prior best who do I work well with
who do I not work well with what do I
need to improve I need to change this
weakness part of my attitude that
doesn't work with this type of people I
need to get better at working with women
or men or couples I need to work better
with people who are twice my age or half
my age I need to learn how to work that
area better so those are 11 skill sets
11 skill sets that millionaires master
and my challenge to you is if there are
any areas here that you want to say man
I want to get better at that as well you
go seek finding out on what you need to
do by being resourceful and finding out
how can I become better in this area and
eventually you'll become better in those
those skill sets as well but this is
going to take effort this is not one
video is going to change everything for
you I'm so excited I'm gonna go dude no
plan of action on improving these areas
score yourself in these 11 areas
good in this I'm terrible in this I
don't even know what this is I got to
get better at this who's good at this
let me contact this person and get
better at it so that's my plan of action
for you guys that I'd like to see you
put together to get the types of results
that you want to get but those are the
11 skill sets of a millionaire a
millionaires mastered Paul throw me my
favorite pillow real quick gang let me
tell you I've been doing this for the
last two weeks now our goal is to get to
a hundred thousand subs on YouTube by
August 31st I'm getting so many great
messages people that are posting our
stuff on Instagram Twitter you know
commenting on YouTube and inviting other
peers and sending it on their newsletter
and all this other stuff which is
helping out tremendously and some of you
guys that are going above and beyond you
know who you are message you out thank
you thank you for doing that but we want
to get 200,000 subs we feel
pound-for-pound we can go against any
other youtube channel on the subject of
entrepreneurship and so if you haven't
subscribed yet please do so if you got
your friends following please help them
also encourage them also subscribe to
this channel I'm launching something
very very massive in August and our goal
is to get to a hundred thousand by the
time we launch that project with that
being said if you saw this video on a
complete different website you can
always come back to Patrick be david.com
boom and if you got any questions or
comments please comment on the bottom
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye bye
you